بالنسبة لموضوع الاجتماع مع
رئيس روسيا ، نعم أود
التوقف لإنهاء الحرب ، فهناك
الطريقة الدبلوماسية وهناك الطريقة العسكرية ،
لذلك يختار أي شخص سليم وعاقل
الطريقة الدبلوماسية دائمًا لأنه
يعرف ذلك حتى  إذا كان الأمر صعبًا فقد يوقفها
خسائر الآلاف من عشرات
الآلاف ومع مثل هؤلاء الجيران مئات
الآلاف وربما الملايين من
الضحايا
ضحايا
خسائر لأشخاص لا نريد ذلك
وأي زعيم سواء أراد ذلك أم
لا.  لديك الحق
في
الرفض بشكل شخصي لأنه سيكون
قرارًا ذاتيًا لرفض
الطريقة الدبلوماسية
كما أنه مهم أيضًا لشركائنا
ويمكنني القول لأننا نتحدث باستمرار
عن ذلك واتخذنا خطوات
معينة
من أجل الحل الدبلوماسي
لـ  الصراع العسكري والحرب مع
الاتحاد الروسي شركائنا في كل من
الأوروبيين والشركاء
من خارج المحيط الولايات المتحدة
وكندا الجميع يرى
أن ما تقوله روسيا
و  من قال خلال كل هذه الأوقات
أن أوكرانيا نفسها لا
تريد الجلوس على طاولة المفاوضات ومن
ثم الحرب يمكن للجميع أن يرى أنها
كانت نوعًا من التأثير المتراكم
والآن
إذا تمكنا من القيام بذلك ، فإننا سنستمر حتى
إن الثقة في طريق شركائنا
إلينا هي أعلى مستوى ولكن لا
توجد ثقة في روسيا ،
فهذه ليست مرادفات ، فهذه
متضادات روسيا وثقة
لأنهم يقولون شيئًا ما
وكلماتهم لا تتطابق مع الأفعال
وماذا عن الأمن  القضايا ، نعم ،
قضايا أمنية لثانية واحدة فقط ،
لذا لا أتذكر الجزء الثاني من
سؤالك ، فأنا لست خائفًا من
مقابلة الرئيس
إذا كنت على وشك محاولة القتل
، فلننتظر قليلاً
ليس لدي الحق في ذلك  خائفون
خائفون لأن شعبنا أظهر
أنهم لا يخافون من أي شيء
يخشونه على أطفالهم ،
هذا صحيح أن الناس كانوا يوقفون الدبابات
بأيديهم العارية والأسلحة العسكرية الروسية الأخرى
وكذلك
قواتنا المسلحة لأوكرانيا  بالإضافة إلى
حرسنا الوطني ،
هناك الكثير من الإجراءات الأمنية هنا ،
لا يبدو الأمر جيدًا بالنسبة لك ، لكنك
ستظل تعلم أنك في أمان الآن بشكل
طبيعي قائد وهذا هو سبب عدم تمتع
القائد العادي
بالحق في  تخافوا عندما
نتحدث عن الدولة
وعن استقلالنا شكرا لكم